es war in der sache aber auch in den
fragen von stil und kultur des
parlaments ein herausfordernder tag
heute
guten abend herr bundestagspräsident
guten an der kleber können sie mit der
leistung zufrieden sein
naja ich hab das nicht zu beurteilen
aber ich finde
insgesamt haben wir's parlament heute
ganz gut gemacht wir haben diskutiert
sind alle auffassungen in einer
vernünftigen form zum ausdruck gebracht
worden es wurde gestritten aber es ging
immer in formel die einen
parlamentarischen debatte angemessen
zentrum und dann wurde entschieden wurde
nicht unterdrückt wurde nicht
abgeschnitten
und da wurde entschieden die mehrheiten
sind klar trotzdem acht monate lang hat
der deutsche bundestag das parlament die
regierung in einer der größten krisen
die die republik je erlebt hat schalten
und walten lassen wie sie das wollte
ohne engen gesetzlichen rahmen zu setzen
das ist vielen hohen gerichten und
rechtsgelehrten viel zu weit gehend
gewesen ihnen auch na ja gut wir haben
ganz so ist es nicht wie sie gerade
gesagt haben wir haben schon am anfang
auch die epidemische lage für für ganz
deutschland erklärte auch im
bundestagsbeschluss das muss auch sein
dass wir sagen am ende überhaupt schon
im märz wieder reale plenarsitzung
gemacht nicht im internet nur sondern im
plenarsaal debattiert gestritten wir
haben der regierung einen den
regierungen von bund und ländern wir
sind ja ein föderalstaat und die viele
sind ja ermächtigungen die wir den den
ländern verantwortlichen geben müssen
als bundesgesetzgeber also wir haben sie
hier konnten nicht schalten und walten
wie sie wollten aber wir haben den
regierungen den spielraum gegeben
in einer phase wo ja niemand wusste auch
die wissenschaft nicht was ist richtig
und wie geht's genau wie ist dieses
virus und was macht man angemessen und
auch immer auf dem stand der neuen
erkenntnisse die sich jeden tag und jede
woche ändern zu reagieren dann haben wir
irgendwann gesagt wir müssen die
voraussetzungen strenger machen enger
machen
der bundestag muss stärker ein
drogen werden und das haben wir jetzt
heute auch nach intensiver vorbereitung
und diskussion gemacht aber eben auch
nach sehr langer zeit
sie sind jurist sie wissen das besser
als die allermeisten das je tiefer ein
grundrechtseingriff ist desto
gründlicher muss er begründet werden
desto mehr brauche eine zustimmung des
parlamentes und da hat man acht monate
sehr wenig gehört wie können sie damit
zufrieden sein
naja ich muss ja nicht beurteilen ob ich
mit dem parlament zufrieden bin oder
nicht
naja ich habe wie man wie man ja weiß
auch darauf gedrängt aber parlament ist
natürlich auch herrschaft der mehrheit
also der bundestagspräsident ist ja
nicht der vorgesetzte des parlaments
aber ich habe darauf gedrängt dass wir
unsere aufgabe wahrnehmen dass wir die
gesetzlichen voraussetzungen so machen
dass wir die korrektur solche
entscheidungen nicht so sehr den
gerichten überlassen müssen im übrigen
muss man sehen
die meisten gerichtsentscheidungen sind
ergangen zu maßnahmen die die
bundesländer ergriffen haben zum teil
sind die gerichtsentscheidungen auch
gerade zu gegensätzlich gewesen selbst
wenn länder gleiche entscheidungen
getroffen haben das kann man nicht ganz
vermeiden aber das war jetzt auch bei
dem gesetz so wie wir es heute
verabschiedet haben die juristische
abwägung wie genau machen wir als
gesetzgeber die eingriffs
voraussetzungen und wie viel spielraum
lassen wir den verantwortlichen in bund
und ländern und situationsbezogen zu
reagieren da kann man unterschiedlicher
meinung sein genau darüber war der kern
des juristischen streits übrigens auch
innerhalb der fraktionen der ich selber
angehört der cdu csu fraktion die spd
wollte etwas einführen dass der
bundestag wenn jetzt neue maßnahmen
verhängt werden
die vollmacht bekommt dort die
technische möglichkeit bekommt zu sagen
halt das erlauben wir nicht mehr ein
einspruchsrecht des bundestages in die
ausführung des gesetzes durch den
bundesgesundheitsminister
die union wollte das nicht wäre das
nicht für die rolle des parlaments für
die sie stehen eine ganz wichtige
möglichkeit gewesen
naja die koalition hat sich auf die
lösung die wir heute beschlossen haben
verständigt keine frage ich wollte hier
so anhören
war nicht nur einfache abnehmen aber nun
sollte ich meine rolle nicht dadurch
schwächen dass ich in einer solchen
frage in der man sich in der koalition
nach einer intensiven beratung geeinigt
hat dann hinterher
eine bewertung in die eine oder andere
richtung abgeben das macht meine
möglichkeiten die begrenzten der partie
natürlich auch wichtig sind in unserer
in unserem verfassungsstaat mich in
meinen möglichkeiten einschränken
deswegen akzeptiere ich was nach
intensiver beratung durch die mehrheiten
beschlossen worden dass das muss ich
auch vertreten und es ist
verfassungsrechtlich nach meiner festen
überzeugung jedenfalls vertretbar aufs
andere bessere lösung gibt darüber kann
man unterschiedlicher meinung sein aber
so ist es in der demokratie
sie haben heute erlebt wie wenige
hundert meter vom parlament weg
außerhalb der befriedeten zone
zehntausende menschen demonstriert haben
die sie mit ihrer nachricht und mit
ihrer arbeit nicht mehr erreichen wie
viel sorge macht ihnen dienen deshalb
machen ihnen diese fliehkräfte in der
gesellschaft ja das macht sorge um so
wichtiger ist dass wir im parlament
denjenigen die zu hören wollen
das wollen nicht alle zuhören aber
denjenigen die durch eine rationale
debatte zu erreichen sind zeigen
es werden alle unterschiedliche
meinungen intensiv geprüft beraten
es gibt änderungen die grünen zum
beispiel haben ja auch in der debatte
gesagt sie sind nicht hundertprozentig
muss einfach sein aber sie haben es oft
sie sind so sehr beteiligt worden auch
bei den änderungen die wir ja heute in
den gesetzentwurf der regierung
hineingeschrieben haben dass sie am ende
zugestimmt haben und es zeigt in die
auch in den internen beratungen selbst
wenn der ablauf schnell war die beratung
war intensiv und es ist mit allen
fraktionen die überhaupt sich an den
beratungen beteiligen sollte eine
fraktion will sich gar nicht beteiligen
mit allen anderen ist intensiv
verhandelt und gesprochen worden so dass
man den menschen sagen kann
natürlich gibt es unterschiedliche
meinungen auch in der wissenschaft aber
es gibt zwei gesichtspunkte die erstens
irgendwann muss man ja wohl auf das was
die herrschende meinung oder die
mehrheit der der wissenschaftler sagt
als politiker
ein stück weit höheren aber noch
wichtiger ist für mich auch immer der
hinweis wenn ich mich umschaue wie ist
es in den anderen ländern
dann muss ich sagen haben wir es
eigentlich in deutschland ohne dass ich
sagen ist alles gut gelaufen aber nicht
so schlecht gemacht und wie gesagt die
rolle des parlaments ist auch bei den
entscheidungen die in deutschland
getroffen worden sind sehr viel stärker
als in fast allen anderen demokratien in
europa darauf lege ich schon großen wert
und wieder ein stückweit na jedenfalls
zufrieden mit uns als parlament
die bilanz des bundestags präsidentin
danke schön herr schober und einen
schönen abend
danke ihnen auch